the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we're going to generalize our
discussion of series to cover series of
functions rather than series of just
constants in other words you'll notice
that up until now what we've been doing
in our discussion of series was have a
bunch of fixed numbers and then add them
you see in the same way that one starts
with constants and ordinarily with
ordinary arithmetic and then starts
talking about functions the same thing
occurs here that maybe we are now
interested in a series over a range of
different values of X now rather than to
talk abstractly about this I'd like to
return to a topic that we touched upon
briefly much earlier in the course and
then come back to that topic with far
greater power than we were able to
exhibit up until now and it's the idea
of approximating a function by
polynomials in other words this question
of degree of contact and again rather
than review that abstractly let's talk
in terms of a picture you see today's
lecture is called polynomial
approximations and the idea is this
let's suppose we have the curve y equals
f of X it's smooth it passes through the
origin and we're told the following we
say look at we're interested in
approximating this curve in a
neighborhood of x equals 0 in other
words at this point here
by various polynomials now the simplest
polynomial of course is a constant in
other words the question is how should
we choose a straight line y equals a
constant y equals P sub 0 of X in other
words a polynomial of degree 0 a
constant if we want the best possible
horizontal line that approximates the
curve at this particular point and I
think you can see that it's rather
trivial at this case to say okay let's
take the horizontal line that passes
through this point see any other
horizontal line misses this point
altogether ok so far so good then
somebody says now look at if we remove
the restriction of the line be
horizontal
what about any straight line what
straight line has the best degree of
contact with the curve at this
particular point in other words what
first degree polynomial has the highest
degree of contact over here
now again sparing you the details
because the details are supplied in the
text the polynomial there is simply what
f of 0 plus F prime of 0 times X in
other words it's the tangent line the
basic equation of a tangent line is y
equals MX plus B where m is the slope
which is f prime of 0 and B is the
y-intercept which is F of 0 over here
now the next question comes up what if
we wanted a quadratic polynomial a
second-degree polynomial that fits the
curve even better in other words has a
greater degree of contact at this
particular point let's label that y
equals P sub 2 of X to indicate a
second-degree polynomial and to analyze
what that polynomial must look like
let's simply write down some
undetermined coefficients here namely
let's let P 2 of X be a0 plus a1x plus
a2x squared and the idea is to determine
what a 0 a 1 and a 2 must look like if
this polynomial is to have a maximum
degree of contact with the curve y
equals f of X now what do you mean by
maximum degree of contact well what you
mean is you want the function at 0 to
equal the given function at 0 you want
the first derivative of p2 evaluated 0
to equal the derivative of F evaluated
at 0 and you want the second derivative
of p2 evaluated at 0 equal to F double
prime of 0 well let's go through this in
slow motion
first of all p2 of 0 is simply a 0 p2
prime is simply a 1 plus 2 a 2 X and
evaluating that when x equals 0 we just
have a 1 so f of 0 must equal a 0 a 1
must equal F prime of 0 now what about
the second derivative notice that every
time we differentiate this polynomial
another term drops out a 0 drops out the
first time a 1 the second time and when
you've differentiated this term twice
all you have left this to a 2 in other
words P 2 double prime evaluated at 0 is
2 a 2
must be f double prime of zero equating
these two a two must be the second
derivative of F evaluated at zero over
two I inadvertently wrote in two
factorial here which is the right answer
but I haven't led up to that yet so if
you want to call this two that's fine I
at any rate his would have shown what
I've shown is that if you want the
polynomial of degree two that fits the
curve the best in the neighborhood of 0
comma F of zero this is how the
coefficients must be chosen and in fact
this situation generalizes very nicely
you see suppose you want the nth degree
polynomial expression differentiate this
n times you see each time you
differentiate one of these terms drops
out what happens to this term as you
differentiate it the first time you
differentiate it you bring down an end
the next time you differentiate you
bring down an N minus 1 by the time
you've differentiated n times this is X
to the 0 that's 1 a sub n is still here
and n times n minus 1 times n minus 2
etc is just what we call n factorial in
other words the nth derivative of P sub
n of X is n factorial times a sub n if
you evaluate that at 0 that's still n
factorial times a sub n that must also
equal the nth derivative of the function
evaluated at 0 by definition of what you
mean an MS degree of contact at any rate
that says that the enth coefficient the
coefficient of x to the n must be the
nth derivative of F evaluated at 0 over
N factorial by the way knows what this
says and we'll come back to this much
more strongly later it says that for
this coefficient to exist the nth
derivative of f at 0 has to exist in
other words if n K if F does not possess
its nth derivative this particular
equation doesn't make sense and I'll
show you what that means in a little
while but at any rate notice that what
we've now shown is that P sub n of X if
you want to use the Sigma notation can
be written how well it's the sum as K
goes from
n/f the case derivative F evaluated at 0
over K factorial times X to the K power
which written out longhand is simply
what a0 plus a1x plus a2x squared over 2
factorial plus etc the nth derivative of
F evaluated 0 over N factorial times X
to the N and what we do is we let P of X
denote the limit of P sub n of X as n
goes to infinity in other words for a
fixed X we look at what the sequence
converges to as n goes to infinity and
we denote that as a series you see what
happens is X is a variable here but if
you replace X by a specific number
what's inside the summation sign becomes
a constant which depends only on N and
we're back to our study of ordinary
series again now what does P of X mean
in this case going back to our diagram
it means that as we let n get bigger and
bigger and we determine more and more
coefficients we get what hopefully
what's a better fit to the curve over
here that we get a greater degree of
contact every time we tack on the next
term in the series now because this may
seem a little bit abstract let's
illustrate this thing numerically let's
pick a specific example and I'll pick an
easy one to compute let f of X be e to
the X after all what could be easier
because the derivative of e to the X
with respect to X is just e to the X so
the nth derivative of e to the X is
always e to the X when x is 0 e to the 0
is 1 so the nth derivative of e to the X
evaluated at 0 is 1 if I divide that by
n factorial I just get 1 over N
factorial in other words the sequence of
polynomials that approximates e to the X
is given by what summation X to the K
over K factorial as K goes from 1 to N
and what again what this means is what
the first approximation is the line y
equals 1 the straight line approximation
at the for the highest degree of contact
at the origin is y equals 1 plus X the
best quadratic approximation is y
one plus X plus x squared over two the
best cubic fit is when y is 1 plus X
plus x squared over 2 plus X cubed over
6 6 being 3 factorial and we can
continue on this way
getting benefits as we add more and more
terms and again I've spoken quite
rapidly the reason being that this pot
is done superbly in the textbook
complete with graphs tables and
what-have-you
now here's the question the question is
looking we can compute PN of X for any
given N and we intuitively get the
feeling that as n increases PN hopefully
will look more like f of X in other
words what we would like to do is to be
able to compare or better still to study
f of X by comparing it with the limit of
PN of X as n goes to infinity in other
words what we hope will happen is that f
of X looks like P sub n of X for large
values of n now we don't know where this
is going to happen in fact the remainder
of our course now revolves about three
questions the three questions are the
following first of all does the limit PN
of X as n approaches infinity exists in
other words does P of X exists in the
first place does this limit always
exists for a given X secondly suppose
the limit does exist how do we know it's
going to equal the given function f of X
which is trying to approximate cause how
do we know that we don't get an
approximation which is nice
near near the point of contact but then
no matter how far out we go beyond the
point of contact the approximation
doesn't become sufficiently good see and
the third question that comes up
assuming that the first two have been
answered is suppose the limit does exist
in other words suppose this limit
function P of X which is a limit of PN
of X as n approaches infinity does exist
the question is does P possess the
polynomial properties that each piece of
n possesses in other words the question
is does the limit of a sequence of
functions have the same property that
each of the members of the sequence has
for example every polynomial is
continuous
the questions for example that might
come up is is the limit of a sequence of
continuous functions also continuous now
at first glance it might seem as if
these are rather trivial to answer let
me proceed next by showing that the
answer can be no can be no to each of
these three questions after which will
then try to show when the answer will be
yes the idea is this
let me call these things counter
examples even though I don't know what
what better word to use here now let me
show you an example where the answer to
each of questions 1 2 & 3 happened to be
false for example let f of X be 1 over 1
minus X as a review in taking
derivatives f prime of X would be 1
minus X to the minus 2 power F double
prime of X would be 2 times 1 minus X to
the minus 3 power C notice you bring
down the minus 2 but the derivative of
what's inside respect to X is minus so
minus times minus is plus similarly the
third derivative of f of X is 3
factorial 2 times minus 3 times minus 1
1 minus X to the minus 4th and in
general the nth derivative of F in this
case is n factorial times 1 minus X to
the what minus n minus 1 in other words
notice that the magnitude of the
exponent is 1 greater than the number
we're taking the factorial of at any
rate if I now compute the nth derivative
of F evaluated at 0 I just get n
factorial and if I divide n factorial by
n factorial I get 1 in other words every
one of my coefficients of the
approximating sequence of polynomials is
going to be 1 in other words the
approximation for f of X where f of X is
1 over 1 minus X is simply what PN of X
is 1 plus X plus x squared etc plus etc
X to the nth power now here's the
interesting point
this part is irrelevant I just wanted to
show you something over here notice that
F of 2 is clearly minus 1 if I replace X
by 2 over here 1 over 1 minus 2 is minus
1 on the other hand what I claim is
that the limit of the sequence P sub n
of X as n goes to infinity doesn't even
exist when X is 2 because look what
happens over here when X is 2 this is
what 1 plus 2 plus 2 squared plus etc 2
to the N that's 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8
plus 16 etc and as I let n go to
infinity that sum increases without
bound in other words here's an example
where the given limit didn't have to
exist in other words the sequence of
polynomials does not converge at all as
x equals 2 okay so much for showing that
the answer to the first question can be
no as for the second question let's
define a function as follows to show you
why continuity is so important let f of
X be x squared if X is less than or
equal to 2 and let it be for if X is
greater than 2 now if we compute the
derivatives of f evaluated at 0 we find
that what f of 0 is 0
see x squared at 0 is 0 2 X at 0 is 0
the second derivative here is 2 so f
double prime of 0 is 2 and the third
derivative and higher since this is only
x squared are identically 0 in other
words notice that the second derivative
of F evaluated at 0 is 2 all other
derivatives are 0 in other words notice
that PN of X is equal to x squared when
n is greater than 2 and that's a
straightforward computation I will drill
you on the homework problems to show you
how to get more facility with doing
these things but here's the key point
let's look to see what the limit of PN
of X is as n approaches infinity since
PN of X is equal to x squared for all N
in particular then since it doesn't
depend on n the limit of PN of X as n
goes to infinity is just x squared what
this says is this our function f of X
graphs like this the sequence of
polynomials which by the way converge to
the limit function x squared look what
they do they're just y equals x squared
in other words somehow or other when we
get to this sharp corner in other words
that f of X is not differentiable at
this point a sequence of polynomials
blissfully went right on their merry way
smoothly while the function itself
leveled off like this in other words the
limit function always exists but as soon
as X is greater than 2 in this example
the function P of X no longer is the
same as f of X you see P of X is going
up like this f of X has just leveled off
this way there are even more glaring
examples but I will leave those for the
supplementary notes to go into in more
detail but so far we've seen what that
the answers to questions 1 & 2 can be no
let's now show that the answer to
question 3 can also be no let's define a
sequence of polynomials P sub n of X to
be X to the N where the domain of P sub
n is the interval from 0 to 1 what that
means is something like this see his
zero zero and I hope this reminds you of
a homework problem that we had very
early in the course but that's
irrelevant whether it does or not P 1 of
X would look like this P 2 of X would
look like this
P 3 of X would look like this in other
words all these curves pass through 0 0
& 1 1
but as n increases the degree of contact
here gets better at any rate let's take
a look at the limit function P of X is
the limit of P sub n of X as n
approaches infinity X to the N as n
approaches infinity well if X is less
than 1 in magnitude X to the enth
approaches 0 on the other hand if X is
equal to 1 1 to the N power is still 1
as n approaches infinity therefore P of
X would be 1 it's 0 if X is less than or
equal to 0 greater than or equal to 0
but less than 1 and it's 1 if x equals 1
now here's the key point
observe that since PN of X is a
polynomial it's in particular continuous
in other words each P sub n is a
continuous function C unbroken on the
other hand look at the limit function
it's zero all the way up to one and that
one the function jumps to one in other
words graph wise the thing looks like
this this is the graph y equals P of X
it's zero all of a sudden that jumps is
the limit function therefore
continuously x equals one the answer is
no there's a jump discontinuity here in
other words observe that each P sub n is
continuous when x equals 1 the limit
function exists but it isn't continuous
when x equals 1 in other words the
properties of a sequence of convergent
functions do not have to be inherited by
the limit function ok that shows then
that the answer to our three questions
can be no what we would like to do is
find out when and if the answer will be
yes what we shall do for the remainder
of today's lesson is answer the first
two questions and this by the way is
also done very nicely in the text the
third question for some reason or other
is beyond the scope of the text we will
discuss this in our future lectures plus
the supplementary notes in fact that the
answer to question number three will be
the end of our course when we finally
answer that particular question but at
any rate what I'm saying now is let's
spend the remainder of today's lesson in
showing how to answer questions 1 & 2 in
the affirmative and we'll save question
3 for the remaining lectures the first
thing I'd like to point out is the role
of the ratio test and absolute
convergence namely given the series
summation a n X to the n and by the way
if you haven't noticed this by now it's
rather conventional sometimes to save
time not to put the subscripts on here
but if it bothers you I mean I could do
things like this adjust that to save
time and space I sometimes will not put
the subscripts on here but any rate
let's just talk about this for a moment
notice that a series converges as soon
as it converges absolutely the point is
that for a positive series I can use the
ratio test or its equivalent namely for
example what I can do is
test summation a n ik absolute value a
and X to the N for convergence by the
ratio test by the comparison test by the
integral test etc okay and what I'm
saying is if that particular series
converges then the original series
namely the one without the absolute
value signs converges absolutely for
that same value of x well again instead
of talking about that let's look at a
particular example it looks like I've
scraped the blackboard here a little bit
let me just the first example is this
let's suppose you look at summation n
goes from 0 to infinity absolute value
of x to the nth power by the way notice
that this is a geometric series with
ratio absolute value of X consequently
this series converges if and only if the
absolute value of x is less than 1 by
the way let me make a little aside here
many people would tackle this problem by
the ratio test as I hinted that over
here namely let the nth term be the
absolute value of x to the nth power
then the n plus first term would be the
absolute value of x to the n plus first
power then the ratio between these two
would be the absolute value of x
therefore row which is this limit would
be the limit of the absolute value of x
ok as n goes to infinity that's just
equal to the absolute value of x itself
and for convergence notice that row must
be less than 1 and that says what the
absolute value of x must be less than 1
just as we did over here I simply would
make like to make a little aside over
here and that is if you use this
particular approach that comes under the
heading of circular reasoning because
you may recall when we proved the ratio
test we did it by comparing the series
with the geometric series which meant
that we already had to know that the
geometric series converged and this is a
geometric series but that's an aside
which I just wanted to mention to you in
forms of circular reasoning the
important point to observe is what that
this series converges if the absolute
value of X is less than 1 consequently
that means that the series without the
absolute value sign converges in fact
Apps
lutely if the absolute value of X is
less than 1 in other words for the for
this particular series 1 plus X plus x
squared plus X cubed etc that will
converge to a finite limit function if
the absolute value of x is less than 1
let's look at another example suppose we
look at the absolute value of X to the
nth power over n factorial if we look at
this the nth term is the absolute value
of X to the N over N factorial the n
plus first term therefore is the
absolute value of x to the n plus 1 over
n plus 1 factorial therefore the ratio
between the n plus first term and the
nth term is the absolute value of x over
n plus 1 Rho is this particular limit
well the limit of the absolute value of
x over n plus 1 as n approaches infinity
and here's the key point notice that X
is a fixed but finite number once we get
started here knows we pick an X and
fixed it that means that that stays
constant
but as n goes to infinity the
denominator increases without bound that
makes the limit equal to 0 and 0 is
obviously less than 1 regardless of what
the value of X happens to be here in
other words in this particular case this
particular series converges for all real
values of X and we sometimes abbreviate
that by saying the absolute value of x
is less than infinity and therefore the
original series meaning the one without
the absolute value sign would in
particular converge also for all relaxed
the important point is that in general
given any series there was limit of a
sequence of polynomials of this
particular type there always exists a
number M now M may be as small as 0 it
may be as large as infinity but there
always exists an M such that the
particular series will converge
absolutely if the magnitude of X is less
than M and diverge if the magnitude of X
is greater than M in other words this
particular M which is called the radius
of convergence governs the answer to the
first question in other words it's this
M which we often find by the ratio test
determines where the sequence of
functions P sub n of X for what values
of x that will converge to P of X and
again I think this is kind of difficult
for you to see abstractly the proof is
done in the text what I'd like to do is
show you pictorially what's happening
over here
see let's suppose we have our series
summation a and X to the N and we pick a
particular value of x say X sub 1 now
but the idea is this if this particular
series converges and the proof is given
in the text and I won't repeat it here
because I want you to see the overview
here if this particular series converges
in other words if the series converges
when X is equal to X sub 1 then it can
be shown that it converges absolutely
for any X which is smaller in magnitude
than X sub 1 in other words that just
assists if I know if the series
converges over here I can then draw this
interval surrounding 0 and conclude that
the series converges in this entire
interval correspondingly if this
particular series diverges and by the
way the whole proof of this thing hinges
on the comparison test essentially see
if this thing diverges then certainly if
X is larger than X 1 in magnitude this
will also diverge in other words once I
know that my series diverges at this
particular value of X 1 of X I know it
diverges for all values of X which are
greater in magnitude than X 1 which
means in terms of a picture for
everything further away from 0 then X 1
and minus X 1 in other words if this
converges this converges in here
if this diverges we have divergence out
here now what does that mean let me show
you again in terms of a extended diagram
see the idea goes something like this
given the series summation a n X to the
n pick a number X equal to X 1 suppose
the series converges at X 1 then we know
that it converges every place in here so
there's no need to check this any
further what we do next is we pick a
number X 2 outside of this interval
x2 was over here suppose for the sake of
argument see what we're saying is a and
x1 to the N converges so you just
suppose this that gives us this picture
suppose a and X 2 to the N diverges then
we know that the series diverges for our
larger values of X now we know how to
series behaves exactly except in the
interval between x1 and x2 so what we do
next is what we pick a number which
we'll call X 3 we then see where this
converges or diverges if the converge is
an X 3 we know that the radius of
convergence extends all the way between
minus x3 and plus x3 if it diverges we
know that from x3 out and minus x3 out
the series diverges in any event each
time we perform this operation we cut
the remaining space down and we can keep
on going this way and you see what
you're doing in is you're zeroing in on
this number that we called capital M
before you see it's just a series of
refinements and by the way the formal
proof of this looks very messy and yet
when it's stripped of all embellishment
that's exactly what the formal proof
says well at any rate I will reinforce
the rest of this between the text the
notes and the learning exercises all one
do now is talk about the second question
in other words we've now talked about
something called a radius of convergence
that tells us when the series of
functions converges to the limit
function now the question is how can we
measure whether that limit function
converges to the original function that
we're trying to approximate in other
words how do we know whether P of X
actually equals f of X and again this is
done extremely well in the text it's
called Taylor's theorem with remainder
the proof is given very very nicely I
think the hardest part is to show what
the thing means you see using
integration by parts repeatedly which is
done in the text it follows that if f
and its first n plus 1 derivatives exist
at x equals 0 it turns out and this is
why this is called Taylor's theorem with
it turns out that f of X can be written
as PN of X plus a remainder term R sub n
of X a remainder term and then you see
computationally the text shows what that
remainder term looks like it happens to
be the integral from 0 to X X minus T to
the N over N factorial F n through n
plus first derivative of F of T DT from
T equals 0 to T equals x this looks
messy it is messy there's no need to
hammer this home in the lecture part of
our course what I prefer to do is to
give several learning exercise that will
give you drill and using this but the
the point that I want you to understand
is that since this is all done well in
the text all I want you to do is to see
where this thing fits in in other words
what the text is showing is look at the
difference between the function which
were approximating at 0 comma f of 0 by
this sequence of polynomials the
difference between that function and the
nth member of that sequence of
polynomials is simply something called R
sub n of X where numerically R sub n of
X looks like this and the point is that
if you now take the limit of this
expression as n goes to infinity
remember P of X is this limit therefore
the only way that P of X can equal f of
X is if for a given value of x this
remainder goes to 0 as n goes to
infinity
in other words leaving the computational
details to the text because it does it
very nicely what we're saying is that
the significance of Taylor's remainder
theorem is that to find out where f of X
and P of X are identical we simply and I
say simply meaning conceptually simply
computationally it might be difficult
what we do computationally is simply
find all those values of x for which R
sub n of X goes to 0 and the limit as n
goes to infinity you see what we've done
is we've now done two things we're first
shown when this sequence of polynomials
has a limit and secondly we've shown
when it does have a Lim
when will it equal the given function
that's trying to represent the question
that still remains is how do we know
that the limit function has the same
properties as each member of the
sequence in fact we've just given an
example where the limit function had
different properties and the question is
under what conditions can we be sure
that certain nice results that we'd like
to be true because they're true about
each polynomial in the sequence actually
are true about the limit function in
fact that shall be our topic for the
next two lessons and these next two
lectures should complete the course at
any rate until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate